哎,讲到交易啊,大家是不是都听过很多那种好像有什么神秘的必杀技或是号称可以让你一息致富的传说?
但真相真的是这样吗?
今天我们就要来深入聊聊巨人节在他那个非常有名的2025年讲座里到底分享了哪些真正的核心智慧
我们不讲那些什么热门名牌哦
而是要来探讨一种更深刻
更有纪律的交力刑法
好我们开始吧
OK今天我们会分成这五个部分来聊
我们会先从打破大家对交易的迷思开始
然后一步一步聊到心态策略纪律
最后会讲到一个更高的境界
就是交易及修炼
基本上就是带大家完整的走一趟
去理解交易真正的本质
好那我们就先从第一个部分开始
我觉得这点非常重要
就是我们得先拆解掉那个最常见
但可能也最危险的一个想法
就是很多人都把交易当成变魔术
说真的
你是不是也曾经在心里想过这个问题
交易到底是不是一个
可以让我们快速致富的捷径啊
我相信很多人都有过这种期待对吧
不过接下来巨人节的观点
可能会完完全全颠覆你的想象
你看哦
这张图的对比就很有趣了
左边这个就是大家的美好幻想嘛
以为交易就是可以一夜致富
只要找到一个神秘公式
然后胜率要非常高
但巨人节告诉我们
现实世界是右边这个样子
根本是两回事
真正的交易是需要常年经验的累积
要建立一套你自己的逻辑框架
而且最重要的是把风险管理摆在第一位我觉得这句话可以说是整个心法的基石所以啊重点来了成功真的不是因为你找到什么
别人不知道的秘密
而是来自于你每一天
每一年在市场里面
不断的练习跟学习
这就像在跑一场马拉松
而不是100公尺的短跑冲刺
OK
所以破除了迷思之后
接下来要谈的
我觉得是更核心的东西
就是在我们学任何策略之前
得先把地级打好
这个地级就是我们的心态
说真的
这才是真正决定
你可以在这个市场上活多久的关键
哇
这句话
我第一次听到的时候
真的觉得很有感触
很多人都以为
做交易要靠那种钢铁般的意志力
要很能斤
对不对
但巨人杰说不是
他说
真正能让你撑过那些赔钱
很痛苦的时刻的
是你对这件事情
打从心底的热爱
就是那种单纯的喜欢
才能让你一直走下去
而且做交易的人
其实真的很孤独
你想想
这不像一般上班
有同事可以讨论
有老板可以问
你做的每一个决定
不管最后是赚钱还是赔钱
都是你一个人的事
这也就代表
你得不断的往自己内心看
很诚实的去复盘自己的每个决策
承认自己哪里做错了
然后去修正它
所以这不只是技术
更多的是一种跟自己的对话
还有情绪的管理
好那心态这个地基打稳了
我们就可以开始来盖房子了
也就是策略
不过哦
据人节这边讲的策略
并不是要给你一套什么必胜的神秘公式
完全不是
他要教你的
是怎么去打造一套专属于你自己的逻辑系统那到底要怎么建立自己的逻辑框架呢?给了这三的步骤第一步很简单就是观察你要从市场里面去找到一些有规律有意义的东西
然后呢第二步是辨识
你要学会在一堆杂讯里面找到真正的讯号
那最重要的是第三步
你要根据你的观察建立你自己的规则
然后不断去测试它
这是一个你自己动手做的过程
绝对不是去抄别人的作业
诶 这句话超重要
看题材不如看结构
怎么说呢
你想想
很多人每天都在追新闻
追现在最红的题材是什么
但那就像在追风一样
你永远追不到
而且很容易追在高点
巨人节提醒我们
更重要的是去理解市场底层的结构
像是供需关系的变化
资金的流动等等
因为结构远比题材来得更稳定
也更能给你可靠的交易依据
好
那到这边
心态有了
建立策略的方法好像也懂了
但还缺一个最关键的
可以把这两件事串起来
把理论变成实际利润的东西
少了它
前面讲的全部都是空谈
那是什么
答案就是纪律
在市场上
纪律才是你真正的优势
这一张图
就把大赚小赔这个概面
讲得非常非常清楚
你看哦
如果我们做到
左边这几件事
比如说严格地执行停损
那会得到什么结果
就是你的每一次亏损
都会是小小的
可以控制的
然后透过适当的部位管理
当你看对方向的时候
你的获利才能真的放大
让你赚的有感
这样一来一往
你的账户才有可能
长期稳定地成长
这就是打赚小赔的精髓现在这个时代大家资讯焦虑都很严重很怕漏掉什么最新的消息觉得拿到消息的速度越快越好
但据人节提醒我们
你拿到资讯的速度快不快
其实根本不重要
真正有价值的
是你能不能有纪律的去理解这个资讯
把它放进你的逻辑框架里去思考
这远比你是不是第一个知道这条消息
还要重要一百倍
OK 讲到这里
我们要准备把前面聊的这所有概念
拉到一个更高的层次来看
因为对于巨人节来说
交易这件事
到最后它的终极意义
远远不只是赚钱这么简单
他用了一个词我觉得非常贴切
就是修炼
你想想看
这是不是很像在修行
交易变成了一个道场
而市场就像一面镜子
把你心里面所有的贪婪啊
恐惧啊
侥幸啊
全部都照得一清二楚
你每一次下单
每一次停损啊
其实都是在跟自己的心魔对抗
都是一次对自我的修炼
所以我们今天一路聊下来
你会发现
巨人节想传达的核心讯息
其实非常清晰
真正的成功交易
是一趟建立在逻辑和纪律上面的旅程
这是一条路
而另外一条路是靠投机
靠打听名牌
找短线技巧
那跟前者是完全不同的事情
那么在结束之前
我想留一个问题给大家回去想一想
当我们进入市场的时候
我们真正想要征服的
到底是那个我们永远不可能完全预测
变幻莫测的市场
还是我们该回过头来
学习如何掌握
那个我们唯一能控制的
也就是
常常不听话的
我们自己